hey guys good evening welcome to our
newest choice class Akagi and Ashish
here and online audience welcome and you
ever you have a bunch of I think a bunch
of we have a group of pastors I'm just
kidding dancers playing police they
don't didn't join aesthetic that's okay
all right
so here's a game played in a lower
section of some German league or
something Leonard Leonard le and H AR D
T sent this game I think as far as I
understand he was black in this game and
he lost and he had a few questions and
I'm trying to analyze this game I fully
analyze the game didn't there is no I
chose it first of all it seemed thorough
the questions were kind of clear and the
second is that I figured that it was an
interesting opening to share and there's
some details to discuss here all right
the Fortner f5 touch defense right now
lets me ask everyone and also our online
audience so how many set up black hats
after playing a five suppose white and
why pledge III against this setup why 23
how many against the MU g3 how many
setup black hats how much all of the
pieces
they're learning which ones Leningrad g6
956 Bishop g7 with d6 you can also play
g6 90s which is design with a 6 you also
can play what you can't play Knight f6
east 610 b6
if I place Knight f3 right you can play
you can play Stonewall is 65 what else
it's 66 which should be 796 right with
Queen yet you can play classical with c6
then you play Queen e8 what else is
there anything else that's about it
that's about it so black hoods is this
not this is very tricky in the smaller
so after Bishop you to be Knight f6 now
okay Leningrad is out of the picture but
what other systems now well you tell me
d65 is one plant would be should be
seven right d v c6 is is one line right
this one setup it's all right
and d66 so given that black hasn't shown
us what he wants to do what shall we do
you think
so a lot of people for example when they
see this the reason I'm asking is that
also for our online audience this is
very important they see this and they
assume that black is going to play d5 ok
and a lot of people like to play Knight
h3 and put sugar 4 against the bishop on
d6 and the end up playing is format h3
which is in my opinion is a bit
inaccurate or maybe very inaccurate
because not black plays Bishop e7 castle
castle and now after c4 d6 now when I
play e5 the knight on h3 is awkward
right so it's better not to commit the
night there so I think actually I
actually let me see if I if my game is
here yeah here's my game so the another
reason I chose this game is that I
wanted to brag about my win huh so in my
game I played at my opponent played d6
right away which is actually not the
most accurate way of playing and after
92 a kind of challenge you know I want
to go if oh right away I was telling him
to play d5 now I actually could play I
tricked later because my Knights are not
kind of so great and after E 5 Castle II
for it kind of became a very interesting
position completely different type of
position make sense
so he kind of caught me but I tried to
Kyrie lies that if if I stay and then
played in just regular moves I cannot
get stuff so muddy so I immediately
entered that position and I and I won
the game actually I was equal but he
messed up so this is actually more
accurate we should be seven and now he
played Knight c3 I believe if I was is a
possible move here which black played
right now the not nh3 has some problems
right but black doesn't have one thing
what does black doesn't what black lacks
in this position what's blacks main
problem black doesn't have development
right there's one more thing also now so
many open lines in the position right
mm-hmm
so what do you think why didn't this
with any moment huh he played their very
first single I'm sorry wait for our
audience because there's a twenty
seconds delay so I'll wait for our
audience to see if what they what they
what do you think of this move they
can't check whatever they want the game
is not in database so that's fine they
can they can try to find the game why
play a very interesting move in my
opinion a good practical move makes it
makes things very difficult over the
board
23 I go see five oh I can't go even king
king c 5-piece evans hang wait
no couldn't be three I go you for I mean
night caster for but then I go knight c6
and I don't know
John proposes defy that is a big
positional mistake because it's all
about we want to free that night on a
streak bring it to the game you should
not play d5 it blocks your own Bishop
and you're way behind in your attack on
the kingside Queen side and they have to
deal with the bad knight on h3 after h6
that night is kind of doomed before
before I go a five for example or a four
or even knight c6 what do you wanna do
against knight c6
okay c5 what it says c5 any other moves
no okay
c5 yeah that's what he played I like
that another move was thinking b3 is
interesting
Queenie eight because that's the plan
you want to play Queenie eight and
Bishop e3 and I was thinking the movies
in an actual game black played knight c6
I don't like that but I like an
off-night
a six defending the pawn on c7 I'm
preparing them off c6 the night goes to
c7 2 is 6 so after Queen d2 c6 now this
two squares d5 mb5 are taken away from
this night and we're kind of in control
of the center and after.look a c1 for
example and the other one goes to d1
right eye which sixth completely
restricting that knight on h3 mm-hmm
okay 51 B should be 6 I think what is
perfectly fine here the problem of the
night unless the trees are still there
you see that might wanna go queen h5 of
for maybe I can talk win this fight
because he's 7 is hanging but maybe
Queen f7 look a e8 then quench 5 black
has gradual process of improvement
although although the result so norm of
G 504 is also possibility right good are
we good on that makes sense so instead
okay like what place if I like to smooth
it d4 runs into CD 695 okay d4 and then
the night constant for right away it
just becomes very active and what is a
heading development if that Knight comes
to the game that is a problem for black
because black is to Tempe done in
development and his king is weak so
unlikely creating a game I found King h8
more appealing because I just get my
king out of the way right now after City
six CD 6d v t5 Queen d8 rope d8 night
Abby should be 3 now what do we do here
just simple 96-95 King g8 okay d1
now here's the last solution
efore you have to kill that Bishop h6 I
got Bishop takes c6 let me tell you and
this is a problem I can maybe take on th
verse I don't know
now this problems this pounds of problem
but maybe maybe it's only maybe close to
losing for black he forest is very
important this was a game I think the C
piano against Azhar of 2008 as I was
looking at so King gets it I like this
better and you know the thing is that
you live your pawns intact before maybe
playable but before then whites whites
whites goals are achieved right he gets
there Foursquare for the night so he
justifies his plan will not manage to me
so I think King actually is a right but
here black Queen yet was the setback of
this move well I mean okay it's not only
about the pawn queen d3 I can't go Queen
f7 right
huh
should be six take-take-take on b7 maybe
but the thing is also I can sacrifice
the pawn and then play knight c6 I'm not
worried about being two pawns down you
can take on b7 I can I can activate my
pieces that's okay I can go King gets
shaky I think couldn't be three I go
King get Jace I'm not worried about
giving up to be set up on take take take
knight c6 black is very active
so he goes see these six I what I like
here is to see the six CD six iveco mp3
check and the 95 and there's also
there's some more so I'd like to smoke
Queen Queen b3 check 95 d4 and now rook
t1 actually I was checking different
modes rook t1 now next one I'm gonna
play 96 skated two bishops right and I
have constant pressure on the pollen
structure I can move the Bishop to g5
III pressure comes to c4 I will be the
first one who gets the C file right
takes Queen takes a five is hanging then
a three will be played it's it's a
constant hassle for black makes sense
doesn't make sense nobody fault huh does
it make sense then okay sounds good then
Simon the man of the man in the arena
it's clicking well that's okay that's
all right that's okay that's good
actually don't have don't have Coke yeah
it's sugar is bad for you yeah sugar is
bad for you I'm just very tired I need
some I didn't have time to brew some
coffee because I need to sleep tonight
so any comments any comments on by any
questions
no good good very quiet folks
okay Nick c5t taxi 595 all right let's
see something's a threat if you take on
d5 Quint XT 595 that's bad as well so I
gotta go Bishop d8 good Bishop g5 this
ninth except six now here's the first
mover first mistake from blacks eyes so
black really well and white miss this
chance
so this Queen e8 was bad then CD is was
okay body he wasn't so good then here he
had to take with a bishop first to have
the knight on d5 right and he take here
and then here black made him sick took
with the bishop I think gf6 is very good
the mesh every six and we still do what
play against that knight on h3 makes
sense makes sense to base family I know
that father if you check that one what
doesn't make sense to you guys make
sense to the audience that he's not
saying anything that's fine it just has
to be we're alive
okay how are we good good know again the
entire the entire idea is against to
play against at night on h3
well obviously is entire idea is to take
insanity the entire ideas based on
playing is that night at h3 keep it out
of the game
there 44 yeah and then I go h5 well you
know your picture is that oh that's that
then you weaken your King as well her
again I mean okay black took the bishop
and then now now you go to Japan but it
was better to keep the bishop on the
board why is it better because when
there are less pieces on the board the
advantage of having an active piece may
not be as visible and when there is more
pieces on the board it's not after he
plays III King at church I think that
wasn't necessary who just copy should be
six I don't think he needs to move the
King unless unless why plays like this
then he can go h5 and then can get you
through he took g8
so keep licking it just fine here I
played a for now I see why it can afford
playing like that but with the bishops
on the board this wouldn't be that easy
right
there's Bishop e6 check the bishop the
bishop and g5 would be on the way if you
put the bishop on a 16 it could be stuck
right so it was hard to find a place for
the bishop if I go back here if I put my
bishop on you three I don't have to fly
with therefore if I put it on the two I
am blocking my own wish my queen right
so it's not so easy to come up with a
plan that to play a four that's why he
takes f6 was so important so now okay
but I mean that doesn't mean black is
worse
okay now the knife comes back to the
game which is not only in the game if
you think about it then what the whites
Knight is not completely outplayed by
start early in the game to deny honor
who doesn't do much unless white managed
to play the move g4 correct hmm at this
moment who has better minor pieces black
has better minor pieces push Bishop e6
can I agree on that does it make sense
to everyone
hmm Queen e2 Queen f7 b3 Bishop c4 was a
threat right and he played a five I
think
you see I've mentioned this most night
before okay night before his computers
move Queen d7 was my move h5 was also my
move computers okay with it if I wasn't
among the top choices I don't understand
what night before this when I go to d5
probably 95 going to c3 that's what
that's what the engine locks I like them
of Queen 7 because you're always ready
to face g4 and let white have to take on
a fight because it can take with a
bishop and if all is well protected
right 27 now you have here you have
protection right and you you always can
play this many where if you want right
so we play a 5 g 4g8 so far so good
Qing er chuan and you played F takes G
for unnecessary now here is a very
thorough question you can spend some
time to work on it 97g takes f5 Bishop
99 takes f5 first first question what
happens after Knight takes e4
yeah that losses right spots right this
is game over so I have to take bishop
takes e4 a for playing active where down
upon by first about different first
matter there aren't so much so many
pawns left on the board right so if you
trade up everything you end up in a
Jewish position second matter is that
what we have to stay active we have
develop material so we have to stay
active so with active play for exampie a
four runs into okay for Luke takes d4 or
Bishop c4 both males are kind of
straight threatening right so I said I
looked at rook Jiwon Murdock g1 I just
can take and take here and take it if if
B takes a 410 Bishop c4 it's not fun to
play
[Music]
so the question is look Jiwon takes
takes takes takes now we cannot take on
v3 f5 f5 is hanging what do we do as
black go in g 7i go before all right we
need some good moves here otherwise
white plays few moves with the knights
and queen f2 and then we're done apart
when you can make some good moves here
you should take say five rock Gy
the thing
okay to quench this is problematic buddy
what do you think Marge III check I take
the Queen age five Queens five
I mean you can play you can play a 5-10
Queen h6 that's very odd because you go
F takes before I go Queen f6 check
actually it's not 100% over you have
them of f5 ah
the thing is that the thing is I can go
Knight h3 neither should 95 I think
that's the problem
I think this is this is the problem so
let's let's look at these lines takes
takes Queen is five what's that well I
mean there's not a move
look at you seven hooks you a check
right okay a check I even came yeah so I
five I think I have to smoke yes
it takes
yeah I think that's the answer huh
yeah and the Queen h6 I think runs into
takes takes hope she won there's still
down upon the answer is play active
mileage for Queen me too well first of
first first off f5 is a threat right fi
was a major threat so Quinn b2 is forced
play Bishop f5 which okay if Bishop g5 I
go but should be six professional so
Roxy one white is trying and then black
plays b5 and said it's a very funny
looks wrong situation what has to what
it does not have an improving move now I
want to take the bishop now you have to
move the bishop and you you keep
attacking the bishop with your Bishop
this game's gonna end in a draw hard to
see what the board but you could
intuitively think that it's you should
have activity on the G file and that
will give you the job probably not that
black is losing with what he did just he
bought himself some trouble so 97 was
the way actually it makes sense right I
mean what is weakening his king so you
have to shift your pieces to order
towards White's King right mm-hmm
makes sense I mean I know I've been
makes sense prepend there's no problem
with that obviously make sense cause you
make sense an audience has nothing to
say right
wrong answers if you have if they have
any questions you know I'll be happy to
address them unless I'm not addressing
them so so so you play F takes G for not
that it's a drastic another thing is
that F takes G for doesn't make sense
you are closing down your own rook right
that's the so now you might say okay I
have a pond near opponent's king but
really doesn't do anything
Bishop d5 okay d1 now there's a threat
of rook takes d5 right okay d8 and I
plays rook takes d5 okay this is a good
move Queen takes d5 takes Queen d2 still
not losing still fine here I found a
very difficult job with black and high
depths with a computer but I think after
a four is very hard to play over the
board Bishop I'm broke I pledged three
you have to place three just mix up
three we can up there I thought I can
place three all right you can place g3
now you've taken statistics and rook f3
but you open up the game and Bishop and
Royal combination to passed pawns right
white black and hold but it's not that
easy it's not that easy
however in the game what takes on c6
doesn't make sense to like this one at
all takes rook g1 and now here's a very
important lesson in the pot in a rook
and pawn endgame when you're done with
material to keep trading because reverse
stroke and pawn there's a good chance
that you can hold so here at five this
inclusion helps black
okay here's the key moment here black
can still hold so he had easy to draw he
had he was in a very good fight but now
he ended up with this endgame so how can
he make a draw this this one this one
deserves to spend some time on I'll give
a little some I'll give you some time to
think about it maybe three four minutes
there's only it's to my surprise there's
only one way to make a draw in this
position what's that
well not it's not about them it's not
only by okay three
took a three also makes a draw it's not
that easy but it also makes a draw
okay three makes a draw okay kingi two
basically turning this is it black to
play okay yeah here okay Roxy five years
okay
okay three here okay three look at five
check proxy five
take that
yeah this is probably a draw
I thought you you have only one best way
to play Brooke history here okay three
Kingi - you said what you do a second G
- King f3
[Music]
that's the draw
okay rook g2
maybe it's probably that's also draw
what I'm trying to say is that I try to
avoid going to these equal end games
very winded III pond and why it starts
to push the connected passports because
it's not only about the equal material
it's about that if white can't control
one of the past pounds of black you
cannot really push your passports but
controlling those two passports is very
difficult I have been on the winning
side of this from white and on the
losing side of it on the black side it
is equally koala and keep on playing but
it's not so easy to play it the
connected passed pawns are far more
dangerous than it seems okay - okay
that's risky still a drop is risky okay
a foreign an a4 I take player key five a
four now a four takes takes rook e5 I
mean maybe you can hold this one too but
I mean it's it's I'm not sure none of
its prob it's very dangerous
yes King e6 is the safest way of doing
it what else anything else yes
eventually rope a three but first
prepare for that so what I figured
- what what seemed the easiest way to me
was to play King e6 okay I try few moves
if I cook in g1 then King D six I'm
supporting my pieces King f1 and then I
go c5 the funny thing is that activity
in the rock endgame is mourning not a
fun thing it's one of the important
principles of the route component again
quality is more important than quantity
I want to go see for a forty three see
what I'm gonna do
efore a4 okay this is easy draw right
if rookie Rookie five this is very
interesting I cooked it for now
if the rook goes back I go back here we
cannot push the pawns
if you don't do that can get you I'll
keep pushing upon what cannot improve
right are we good doesn't make sense
well you make sense so c5e for a for
this is a this is the way to do it okay
wait a second King six
okay I will tell you for if effect if I
go if all right here Derek have to
attacking that pawn up g6 check King f7
and if I go a five here he I love this
one rookie 2 rookies 6 it seems like
white is making some progress but the
King is cut off on the second rank right
c5 c4
I really like this idea now let's see
what happens so if I go through k6 i
just take on e4 okay four and then route
king of six and that's it right
I taken ranking goes to see it right is
it wrong
makes sense yeah glad yeah you could
actively in short secure the draw ensure
your draw with the with the with active
play when does it make sense for for the
audience any questions about this
silences make sense fantastically that's
fantastic well we would like them to
talk but if you make sense fantastic
this is another another one the most
challenging one is rookie five checking
these six
kingi one still see five I'm here okay
three now your plan also works you are
your idea works to c5 and same idea c4
and also Loki three works but now here
what's the best way to make a draw
look checking our work before yes you
sacrifice a pawn rook it takes a rook
takes a five
it'll take c4 you have to eliminate one
other two parts you give up two other
two you give up your two and then this
is just a simple draw then we know the
familiar position right I mean this is
the draw right
it's a side defense this is he cannot go
he cannot go any further and that's the
place to go because if I mean I think it
should be also draw yeah because we have
you looking for check but not here right
Oh still what's that I could you can
took it apart - sorry yeah yeah yeah you
can just take the part of Caffe but even
not that you can just stay here
it's a fold our position is so simple
anyways it was I think it was an
interesting game so what happened then
you think what do you think was if I was
it a good move or not if we want to give
let Leonard Leonard
and at the end har DT I hope you like
the analysis kind of we moderately
managed to analyze it let's see what
happened actually how he lost the game
actually he played this move this place
c5 after this what happened is that the
problem is not here he was not in time
because we need to provoke him of before
if the pawn was only four we could go
Roxy to take the pawn and then attack
the connell on e4 but now this King is
active and there's no pawn on e4 to take
that extra tempo diff makes makes a huge
difference
the funny thing is that do you usually
think that are I do not have to provoke
my opponents pawns to be pushed
right but in that case if the pawn is
pushed is further away from the King so
the King cannot the king could not reach
out to the pause of support them in time
but in this case
not provoking them to push is that they
were they were kind of behind and the
King had just a couple of Tempe to get
them now this is probably totally lost I
don't think so yeah
I mean if sis I think the nicest ways
actually play King g5 can give six so he
lost the game so let's go back to the
position right that was a critical
moment c5 right javi since we have
looked at everything let's go back to
that position all right so is Queenie
eight so where did where did black go
wrong what's the sakuni it was a mistake
but then so he had to go King at [ __ ] I
like to speak up the eight do you think
this is the main mistake Bishop takes f6
what do you think there is some turning
point or maybe that F takes G for what
do you think because it's not only about
what what what the engine says it may be
zero zero for a long time but what
matters is where and at what point did
the Train of the game changed it changed
to it to change into a different
momentum changing to different the
dynamic where black wasn't accustomed to
when you give up the pot what do you
think Ben it's not about making sense
which moment was a critical moment in
this game so for the benefit of our
audience and whoever may watch this
video when I was my game I tried to find
the critical moments or were the board
critical moments not only okay I made
this mistake I had plus one and a half
and then I made this mistake and is now
plus 0.5 if I cannot see it if I don't
see it if it doesn't make sense to me
it's not a critical moment what matters
is to find the critical moment the
moments that you understand and you
missed and the moment that the trend of
the game the way the game was going
changes you were talking about now you
have the defense now the game was equal
but now it's still equal but it's not as
easy as it used to be so you were to
relax to play those moments so if I were
to talk about the critical moments of
this game the first one is obviously c5
right that's immediately right right in
the opening right and then I think the
second critical moment I don't consider
this one very critical this G takes f6
or not but I considered this moment very
critical King gets it
because I think that extra temple with
Bishop e6 could have helped him a lot
and he wouldn't have gone through all
this hassle of dealing with g4 and and I
find this again here F takes you for
another critical moment because he lets
go of his activity with the F text you
for so black switches from being on the
active side of the game to the passive
side of the game and the next one
actually he did not miss this critical
moment he found this idea 22 I actually
he deserves exclam here
he's obviously this moment where he
played his rookie 2 which got him into
trouble
maybe there's a draw I don't know but
King g6 actively was what could secure
him with a draw
all right
any questions no nothing everyone call
so I had another officer sorry no that
was so somebody else are the question oh
sorry I should not open my email right
here I can't let about that I really
should not open my email wait a second
was a game and here's the game I should
have entered this game earlier so
someone asked the question about not
winning winning positions so I'm going
moderately what's that yeah I read
through it and the problem of converting
a winning position so first of all for
first and foremost the most difficult
task in chess is to win a winning
position if you can be good at that and
you're in really good shape so in this
game what is a papon simply in a knife
exactly symmetrical but what is simply
up a pump like has no compensation zero
compensation so you want to talk about
winning this position so what is
incomplete inc in complete control and
it's totally dominate the board I'm so
tired
sometimes I say things okay what was
what's the whites main advantage they
strap on right you the first thing you
have to think about is to trade-offs
which trade-off is the most common is
the most probable one in this position
okay knock right on the edge fold right
is the night and again winning that's
the first question you have to ask
yourself
it is probably winning also if you were
in doubt yours can recall what but
thinks about the 1998 games they're not
thinking electronic games if you are
done if you are done in pawn in the
night in games or in opponent games you
you may end up losing and that's pretty
much the case here so that being said
what movie would you have played here
yep right you too then you go at for
your night can go to e3 so if you go C 5
C takes D for your night can simply
supported you can go at 5 so that's the
first miss button ok even though he did
not do well he still managed to get his
this winning position and then I point
play the smoke in desperation takes and
takes on a fight now for winning this
game the most important thing is that
find the easiest solution do not try to
hold them ok what's it yeah you need
your look to be active right so actually
actually I'm not going to take on a
three I want to get to this this pawn I
would go here I'll go here
so now if I if I want to do that if I go
here
96 ok now this line is kind of getting
active right so I had to win this part
and you have enough activity you go okay
7 a 4 a 4 a 5 right that's it's winning
right well how winning is it
doesn't seem as obvious to me but now
you can play this my huh in the game in
the game white played the smoke c4 a bit
early 96 and now he can't go to catch 3
when you have a winning position
dominant winning position always prepare
this is not that easy and as you can see
we are making mistakes but first
activate your pieces now rook is much
favorable over over a knight right so
use use it as a is in the most efficient
way another way to play is was this
maybe 96 and now to catch one maybe
because if take now I have can get 4
so in terms of plank III I will conclude
with a few become additions for winning
a winning position first thing is that
to win a winning position always study
prophylactic selective don't open your
emails when you're live streaming for
winning I suggest you to go on the
websites that they live like they show
the tournaments going on live and watch
the bar for example chess 24 or even
default only chess or chess calm or all
of them potential lives chess bomb and
see the the where the board changed goes
up and down you know see this first one
and suddenly what makes the mistake so
why he made a mistake and try to
understand learn those and collect those
positions for yourself and review them
if the collection part is the easy part
the review is the harder part every time
you look at it there is something wrong
what about this small by the way I think
as this but you learn about opponents
counter play the possible it is and that
way you start to developing an eye for
okay I got this kind of advantage how I
can convert it that is the best way to
do it
but self learning specific book about it
I don't know not to my knowledge there
are many books out there that they teach
you techniques but converting the
winning position because there are all
kinds of winning positions we get from
time to time I will just try to find
positions from tournament games where
one side made me made a mistake and try
to learn how to convert those positions
okay I think that's about it for now we
will have another one about the modern
errors sorry for the Romantic era of
chess we'll do some check way together
and also I'll show a game of mine
inspired by by by a romantic game so we
can look at it together all right
any questions how good we'll see you in
six minutes
[Music]
you
you